does a young individual smell different
than an older individual and we're
trying to determine what those chemicals
are if there are differences there and
can humans perceive those so now we've
collected t-shirt samples from our
donors and in this study we're looking
at age and this is a t-shirt from an
older male aged 60 to 80 years of age so
he's washed out for about one week with
on fragrant soap and now he's worn this
t-shirt for 18 to 24 hours so I'm going
to hold my nose and cut out about a 4 by
4 inch square of the underarm region of
the t-shirt all right so now this
t-shirts added to the pool with three
other older male donors and then what we
do is be transferred these t-shirts for
a solvent extraction we then use
solvents to extract the contents we
basically let this sit and extract
chemicals for about an hour and then we
remove the solvent we add chloroform at
different solvents and let that sit for
about an hour we then add base example
and clean and wash and purified example
and track the organic acids that were
interested in analyzing and then it's
this solvent that's transferred into the
GCMs for identification of analysis we
also have something called a GC o G C
stands for gas chromatogram and the O
scenes for old fact ometer so what that
is is it uses your nose as the detector
so rather than having an instrument like
a mass spec detect and identify the
compounds for us we actually use our
noses as the detector
you